juin 1972 à stockholm
la capitale suédoise accueille des
milliers de délégués et plus d'une
centaine de dirigeants du monde
certains arrivent en voiture d'autres
ont la possibilité de circuler à vélo
[Musique]
un moyen de transport à propos pour la
toute première conférence sur
l'environnement humain
[Musique]
c'est le début d'une conscience
écologique collective s'ensuivra une
éclosion de ministère de l'environnement
dans de nombreux pays et la naissance du
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement le secrétaire général du
sommet le canadien maurice strong conclu
que l'humanité biais de collectivement
dégrisé
soit
la première ministre de l'inde indira
gandhi rappellera que ces choix
difficiles concerne tous et chacun
[Musique]
un rendez vous est alors fixé tous les
dix ans pour prendre le pouls de la
planète
tenue en 1982 en pleine guerre froide la
conférence de nairobi tombe rapidement
dans l'oubli
mais dix ans plus tard la conférence de
rio de janeiro - rebaptisé sommet de la
terre marque un moment charnière et la
société civile y attend de pied ferme
les dirigeants du monde
même des enfants comme seven cole et
suzuki- la fille de l'écologiste david
suzuki veulent se faire entendre effet
crise
les délégués accouche d'importantes
conventions sur l'environnement et c'est
à ce moment que prend forme la
conférence des parties sur les
changements climatiques les coop le
concept du développement durable lui
devient le nouveau credo
le sommet de 2002 à johannesburg se
tient un an après les attentats du 11
septembre la sécurité semble être la
seule priorité et l'absence de george
w.bush mines les négociations le
président français jacques chirac
marquera toutefois les esprits avec son
discours notre maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs soit au
premier ministre ou le sommet suivant à
rio se déroule sur fond de crise
financière ces accomplissements sont
timides cinquante ans plus tard les
délégués se retrouveront ici à stockholm
où tout a commencé
on discutera de ce que le secrétaire
général de l'onu appelle la triple crise
planétaire celle des changements
climatiques de la dégradation la
biodiversité et de la pollution mais en
vérité les attentes restent modestes
parce que maintenant les grandes
décisions se prennent dans d'autres
rendez vous comme les coques et ce
sommaire est l'occasion pour la société
civile de se faire entendre ici elisa
céret radio-canada stockholm